charlotte david foenkinos a reçu deux
prix littéraires en 2014 le prix
renaudot et le prix goncourt des lycéens
c'est donc pas une nouveauté il ressort
cette année pour noël en version
illustrée donc avec les toiles de
charlotte salomon en fait à la suite de
la parution de son roman david foenkinos
a eu beaucoup de demandes de la part
d'électeurs qui avaient besoin en fait
d'avoir une image associée à l'histoire
de cette jeune juive donc un petit
rappel sur l'histoire de charlotte donc
charlotte salomon faisait partie des
soeurs intellectuelle de berlin la
seconde guerre mondiale à l'arrivée des
nazis elle fuit vers la france
pendant cette période elle va rencontrer
l'amour de sa vie
et alors qu'elle est installée dans le
sud elle répond à la demande des
allemands de se faire répertorier pour
tous les juifs
et c'est comme ça qu'elles se retrouvent
en camps d'extermination donc se sentant
menacée elle a donc confié toutes ses
oeuvres un médecin et c'est donc grâce à
lui qu'on peut avoir aujourd'hui une
version illustrée du roman de david
foenkinos
aujourd'hui je vous présente cité babel
le grand livre des religions qu'un
documentaire jeunesse de pascal et de
l'ain et gaëlle du hazé alors c'est un
documentaire un peu particulier qui est
découpé en quatre 4 parties et en fait
tout se décline dans le livre donc en
fait on va suivre les goûts trois
grandes religions monothéistes donc au
départ ont donc on va voir ici l'islam
le judaïsme le catholicisme ici et en
bas on va avoir une personne apte et est
donc comment vivre dans cet immeuble l'a
donc en fait le
le documentaire est déclinée sur les
trois étages de l'immeuble comment
cohabitent ces familles et quelles sont
les différentes fêtes religieuses
quelles sont les différentes coutumes
les habitudes religieuses de chacun et
chacune et comment tout le monde arrive
à vivre ensemble dans cet immeuble est
donc la famille du balat qui est la
commerçante elle voit un peu passé
toutes ces religions là et toutes ces
personnes qui sont aussi de enfin qui va
aussi des personnes polythéistes enfin
voila c'est un peu le maillot est le
point central de l'immeuble sur les
trois religions qu'on voit là ce qui est
vraiment très intéressant dans ce
documentaire là c'est quand on suit
vraiment toutes ces familles là tout au
long de l'année et tous les liens qui
peuvent avoir entre ces trois familles
là et voilà et cette présentation la en
spirale des trois étages c'est une façon
très iconoclaste on va dire enfin très
particulière de te présenter ça à
l'enfant et donc il ya souvent faim il
ya systématiquement un petit texte qui
vient expliquer le contexte de la
cérémonie et comment la famille décline
sert lui aujourd'hui dans sa vie de tous
les jours et donc la toute dernière
famille qu'est la famille commerçante
elle voit donc passer des gens qui sont
plus polythéistes et donc on raconte
aussi en tant qu on décrit un peu la vie
des personnes donc d'autres religions
donc une braise sous la cendre est une
nouveauté en roman adolescents de saba
attahir chez pocket jeunesse
alors on va se retrouver un petit peu
dans la lignée d'un eagle games avec des
héros qui sont des adolescents on est
dans un monde qui ressemble légèrement
au nôtre mais qui a été modifiée ou dont
les règles ont été modifiées en tout cas
il y à des castes dominantes des élites
des castes plutôt derrière des gens qui
sont réduits en esclavage voilà ça c'est
un peu le cadre de cette histoire et on
va suivre deux personnages un jeune
garçon qui est destiné qu'est voilà
qu'il ya une grande destinée visiblement
une destinée plutôt guerrière il est
pour avoir une décision un peu
manichéenne il est dans la caste des
méchants mais c'est un personnage bien
plus complexe voilà donc je peux pas
trop vous en dire mais en tout cas et
voilà c'est pas s'il manichéen que ça et
on va suivre également le destin d'une
jeune femme qui s'appelle la ja dont le
frère a été enlevé par la caste
dominante par un masque et qui elle va
tout faire pour intégrer ce groupe
dominant pour donner des informations
pour pouvoir libérer son frère
voilà c'est une vision un peu sombre du
monde mais que les ados aiment bien
c'est plein de suspense est très bien
écrit ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas
en littérature adolescente c'est
vraiment un très bon roman ado je vous
présente la place de la planète positive
donc c'est un recensement pas exhaustive
mais au moins de toutes les initiatives
qui sont mises en place pour combattre
un peu nos croissance folk soit en
termes démographiques écologiques
économiques
donc voilà donc c'est un peu une vue de
synthèse de tout ce que les gens font et
mettre en place tout à travers la
planète sur comment combattre les
perspectives qui sont pas vraiment
réjouissantes pour nous tous que tout ce
que les sociétés alternatives ou les
les fonctionnements alternatives ont pu
être mises en place pour voilà pour
combattre un peu ce que l'on vit
actuellement
donc on voit systématiquement fatiha dix
thématiques qui sont décrits décliné
dans le livre ça va de l'écologie à
l'économie circulaire à la politique à
l'éducation et donc sur chaque partie de
sur chaque chapitre en fait on a on a un
planisphère qui vient situé en fait
chaque initiative donc on voit à peu
près qui fait quoi et dans quelle
proportion de bons conseils à peu près
quel pays enfin quel continent on va
dire axione plus ou moins sur certains
levier et fonctionne plus ou moins bien
sûr sûr c'est sur ces leviers tout au
long du livre on vient étayer donc ces
fameuses initiative la citoyenne par des
exemples bien concrets par exemple un
indien qui a mis en place un régime
réfrigérateur naturel avec déjà un autre
au kenya qui a mis des panneaux solaires
pour justement distribuer l'électricité
pas voir toutes ces initiatives que la
société peut mettre en place pour
justement améliorer un peu notre
quotidien et surtout améliorer le futur
et sue et donc se pose vraiment la
question de la perspective et de
qu'est-ce qu'on peut mettre en place
pour voir un peu plus loin et pour
répondre à la problématique qui nous est
posée là actuellement concernant tous
les soucis qu'on en terme d'écologie ou
d'économie